- A builder needs to add
cross braces to a 3.5 meter
by five meter opening between
supports in a building,
as shown in the figure above.
Okay, so this is 3.5 meters
high, five meters wide,
and then this right over
here is a cross brace.
So that right over there is a cross brace.
There's another one that goes that way.
So which of the following is closest
to the length of one of the cross braces?
And they give us four options here.
And so let's look at this.
So closest to the length
of one of the cross braces.
So if you look at the cross brace
that I have started to shade
in here in this navy blue,
you see if you look at that,
and then you look at this five meter side,
let me do this in a brighter color.
If you look at this, and then you look
at this five meter side,
and then you look at this 3.5 meter side,
you see that they form a right triangle.
And so if we wanted to solve
for the length of the cross brace,
that cross brace is a hypotenuse
of the right triangle.
It's the longest side
of that right triangle.
And so we know that we can apply
the Pythagorean theorem here.
We know, or the Pythagorean
theorem tell us,
that the length of the sum of
the two shorter sides squared,
so five squared plus 3.5 squared
is going to be equal to the length
of the hypotenuse squared.
So let's just call this length h,
or actually we could call it c,
if we're used to using the
Pythagorean theorem calling
this a,b,c, and say a squared
plus b squared is equal to,
let's call that c, c for cross braces,
is equal to c squared.
Now five squared is
pretty straightforward.
That's going to be 25.
Now 3.5 squared.
Let's see, 3.5 times 3.5.
Five times five is 25.
Three times fives is 15 plus two is 17.
Now we'll use the three.
Three times five is 15.
Three times three is nine, plus one is 10.
Five plus zero is five.
Seven plus five is 12.
One plus one is two.
And then you have one right over here.
And you have two digits to the
right of the decimal points.
You're going to have
two digits to the right
of the decimal point right over here.
So this is going to be plus 12 plus 12.25
is equal to c squared.
Now 25 plus 12.25,
that's going to be 37.25
is equal to c squared.
Or we could say that c is equal
to the square root of 37.25.
Now let's think about what this is.
We know that six squared is equal to 36,
and we know that seven
squared is equal to 49.
So c is going to be between.
Actually let me write this down.
So let's see, let me give
ourselves some more space.
Six squared is equal to 36,
and seven squared is equal to 49.
And we know that c
squared is equal to 37.25,
which is closer to 36.
It's larger than 36,
but it's closer to 36 than it is to 49.
So I'd approximate c would
be between six and seven.
It's going to be closer to six.
And so let's see, out of
our options right over here,
6.1's looking pretty good.
It's definitely not going to be 8.5.
8.5 squared is going
to be greater than 64.
So it's not going to be that.
3.6 meters squared,
well that's going to be less than 16.
So 6.1's looking good.
This is going to be a
little bit more than 36,
which 37.25 is, it's a
little bit more than 36.